目指す今日はねコーンでも可愛い友達を連れてきたの
[音楽]
今日連れてきた友達はこの2人目ちゃんです
可愛いねおっ2の商の家の方は普通のメルちゃんですショートヘアのかわいい女の顔し
は台数減ちゃんお風呂に入れると会う時が空いるんだったりしますね
かわいい今日もう一人方音など入るなぜこちら神になるの長い女の子だね
ここはメイちゃんのささぁ論文のお友達メルちゃんの
友達だね可愛いねどこには名前がないから多くな名前をつけてあげるんだって言って
このローメディアの女の子の名前はねぇどうしようか
女の子の名前は届けちゃうぅんかわいい長いだねっ
じゃあさっそく挙げてみよう何度主役のめちゃんですよじゃあさっそく挙げてみ
ましょう
憂ちゃん可愛いねただ使ってるみたいよ
ダッシュわーんっ
vector 今日から僕のお友達のめちゃんだよみんな
二役してねもう1人お友達連れて行きましょうウォーカーそうでなんかロリコンとか
じゃないんですけども
どっちかというとこういう買い方女の子とお金好きなんだよねうんねめちゃん
じゃあお友達の方も上げていきましょうこっちの方が俺は好みだ
どっちかと言われると俺はこっちの方が好きだな
あの離婚じゃないよロリコンじゃないけどこうなんか女の子の髪型とかっていうという
もんなんですできた
で建てたよなーすべきたが轟きちゃんですねこの子が目ちゃんのお友達の轟きちゃん
ですこいつの方
あっ違った
届きさんには串と飲んだんだがついてね
[音楽]
本当に可愛いので今日はね今度は一人と遊んでみようと思いますすーっ
ppap ん
th
襲撃はですねこのめるちゃんと登録ちゃんでねタイマン対決をしてもらおうと思います
俺はねずっと疑問に思ってたんですよこいつらのどっちが本当に強いかっていうのを
これははっきりさせたいと思っ今日はこの2人タイマーを張ってもらおうと思います
僕的にが僕的にも完全にこの女ちゃんのお友達の方がずっと好きなん
好みの問題ですけどねビジュアル的にはこっちのメイちゃんのを立つのが好きなんで僕
はこっつつ応援してます
どっち物理かっていうのを今日は検証してみようと思います
タウンすみだね
各コーナーより入場しますが天下一品の大町もの
おせわだいすきメルちゃんですシック分ワンピースに進まれて済むボディ
魅惑の yamaha the 36度以上の愉悦取る髪の毛のピンク色に変化まさに
メタモルフォーゼでございますようてから伸びるその人差し指なに送り出すのかと9人
の超能力サイクますで相手を地獄へ導けるのか
テクニカルだーた
会が楽しみでございます続いて青コーナーから入居するはメルちゃんの友達
さらさらロングの友達とだけじゃねぇ
さらさらのためので超級てくるでございますロングヘア月の初めには留まりません
おおっとロリコンじゃないですよコーナー嫁ちゃんさんの良さそうなの九実は経営の中
今回のタイマンバトルで決着をつけたい様でございますさあ主役の座は奪い取れるのが
驚くチャー出陣です
どっちが勝つか全くわかりませんねまあ僕はね
多くの神時長いベンチャーがお友達なんですよねさあ
ステは戦いを見守りましたかわいい戦い楽しいですね
わっ
スタートッッッ
さあの次勝っかなどっちが勝ったんだけどどっちれた
またないさん来てる撮ったから
[音楽]
b